well former Vice President Joe Biden is
president Trump's latest target Biden
the latest candidate to enter the 2020
race condemned the president during his
campaign announcement where he says he
can't stand by and watch eight years of
Donald Trump in the White House now mr.
Trump continues to go after his most
notable presidential opponent while
attacking the 76 year-olds age Nikole
Killion is at the White House with the
very latest Nicole good morning good
morning to you Michelle president Trump
and former Vice President Joe Biden
continued a jab at one another despite
reports the president views Biden as a
threat he is showing complete confidence
in his chances for re-election president
Trump didn't hold back on the man he
calls sleepy Joe I am a young vibrant
man I look at Joe I don't know about him
former Vice President Joe Biden who
officially entered the presidential race
this week responded Friday on the view
if he looks young and vibrant compared
to me I should probably go home the spat
comes after Biden's 2020 campaign video
criticized the president's response to
racially charged violence in
Charlottesville in 2017 she said there
were quote some very fine people on both
sides and in that moment I knew the
threat to this nation was unlike any I
had ever seen in my lifetime people were
there protesting the taking down of the
monument of robert e lee everybody knows
that keep America great the president
was in full campaign mode at the
National Rifle Association convention
where he announced the US would pull out
from a global arms trade treaty I'm
impressed I didn't think too many of you
would really know what it is and he
continued to play to his base with
strong words about the mulher
investigation they tried for a coup
didn't work out so well
he doubled down on his comments in a
meeting with japan's Prime Minister oh I
think absolutely well last night the
president had dinner with the Japanese
Prime Minister and this morning they're
going golfing then it's back to the
trail for the president he is holding a
campaign rally in Wisconsin and will not
attend tonight's White House
Correspondents Dinner for the third year
in a row Dana
all right Nicole thank you